millions of people flooded streets
around the world demanding action ahead
of the United Nations climate summit
next week protests were held more than a
thousand locations from New York to
California and overseas from India to
Japan Kenya and Australia in what is
being called the largest climate strike
ever Hillary Lane joins us with more on
this Hillary good morning good morning
the protests in more than 150 countries
were led by young people many skipping
school to take part all to send the
message that elected officials need to
do more to combat what they call the
climate crisis it was a sea of people
from the Midwest to the west coast and
all around the world calling for action
now to stop climate change our
generation is the one who's going to
have to deal with the repercussions of
irresponsible climate policy teenagers
organize the climate strikes inspired by
the Friday's for future campaign led by
16-year old Swedish activist Greta tune
Berk the mission student walk outs every
Friday until elected leaders make
changes to protect the environment I
think that if enough people go together
and 100% green renewable energy by 2030
and no new fossil fuel projects is the
goal for protesters like Sarah sure
Linder I think this is showing white
kids can do and how we can change the
world and I think we need to like
represent some school districts across
the country gave students the option to
skip school Friday with parental
permission this helped fuel rallies like
one in Florida where 17 year old Nicole
Buckley demonstrated of tech workers
also protested from companies like
Twitter Google Facebook and Amazon which
on Thursday announced a commitment to
net zero carbon by 2040 and 100%
renewable energy by 2030
the science says we cannot take any more
fossil fuels out of the ground so if we
do wanna show bold climate leadership
which Jeff said we want to leave we
can't be in business boiling gas the
United Nations climate summit convenes
in New York Monday there are world
leaders are expected to reveal their
plans to step up efforts to curb
greenhouse gases there's another
worldwide climate strike planned for
next Friday just goes to show you that
the power of one that one teenager Greta
yeah I'm sweet and young people worried
about their future Hillary thank you